it's time for an important ceremony
that we have not uh done in a while
state of the podcast this is where we uh
what is you know it's called it's like
State of the Union once a year the
president talks about the state of the
country and it's usually a lot of
nothing but uh
[Laughter]
let's see if we can top it well I'm just
saying there's a state of the podcast we
take this we take our job seriously here
yeah and this is where we talk about
where we are and what we've achieved
Matt Gourley I look to you because I'm
just uh I'm just the chimp that they've
put into the Soviet Space Capsule yeah I
don't know I've just been you got that
right wait why don't you look at me
because I don't
think you're really paying attention to
that is this true yeah you're right I'm
just being completely honest but Matt
Gourley you are a professional you are
brought into pre no seriously you were
brought it no no it's not a dig against
you it's a dig against myself too you
were brought in as this professional
podcast man this uh
this magical man who could take these
clownish fools and turn this into a
really good podcast and you did that and
you're we owe you a debt of gratitude
and also you have a perspective on how
the podcast is going I would think how
do you think it's going I think the
state of the podcast is strong we've
branched off by now into satellite radio
there's a solid and strong thriving
YouTube channel of of clips from this
show and I think I'm just working under
the grand tutelage of Adam sacks who we
usually bring in on these segments
because he's the the real poobah yeah he
is the man some say the the dark force
behind the throne right the emperor the
emperor I'm just Vader he's the emperor
yeah yeah um what is his name Palpatine
yeah Chief Palpatine what is it she of
Palpatine shiv what do you mean shiv
that's his first name that's his first
name he had a first name sure well he's
got to live doesn't he does he I thought
his first name was Emperor no that's his
darks like Darth tyrionis person Sonic
he was a Senator on Naboo for a year
it's terrible that we went down this uh
little cul-de-sac this is a cul-de-sac
of death let's get to the point you
asked yes
the state of the podcast according to
Matt Corley is from but we're bringing
now uh in uh Adam sacks
um who's the Man Behind The Man Behind
The Man Adam tell us how you feel it's
all going it's going very well Matt
touched on a couple of the big things
that are some of the important updates
you know when kovid hit and we left our
Warner Brothers Studio and we went on to
zoom it sort of forced us to start to
incorporate video into our podcast
because we were on video on Zoom we were
always before that like let's keep
cameras out you know we wanted it to be
a very camera-free environment people to
sort of forget where they were and just
have an intimate conversation and
sometimes cameras can impact that but
being on zoom over covid forced us to
introduce cameras and then we started to
capture this YouTube video and
eventually we were like well we also
happen to have a you know robust YouTube
channel with a lot of followers let's
try and put some of this video content
out there and see what happens and it
did really well and our existing YouTube
fan base was excited to see what you all
look like I have a lot of fans that
watch me on television for almost 30
years who were just excited to see what
I look like wow which is unbelievable I
just like they constantly were draping
blankets over the television really I
got hundreds of hundreds upon hundreds
of comments about how old I look
compared to how you made me seem
just brutal like that's him you know did
that hurt your feelings yeah what did I
do I just Ben made you clearly made you
seem youthful and vibrant no you made me
seem like a carnival teen
well anyway my mom I didn't come here to
be accused of anything so it sounds so
the zoom video did well
but our fans were accustomed to high
quality video and the zoom video looked
like crap for the most part right now
that we have this really you know
state-of-the-art studio with high
quality cameras that do sort of
disappear into the background we did I
will say uh during the pandemic
um when we were doing the uh podcasts on
Zoom for reasons I still don't
understand we used 7-Eleven security
cameras that's right yeah and they were
set at the same angle and we all had to
go into separate 7-Elevens to record
yeah exactly and then we were all robbed
while we were recording but we did uh
catch the the villains
um yeah so this is interesting to me I
want to point out this thing that I
noticed
so I'm in television and then I decide
you know I really I want to strip it
down I want to do long-form interviews I
don't want there to be any video I just
want it to be audio and I'll talk to
people and after all these years of
doing six and seven minute interviews
I'll really get to explore all these
areas that I never had a chance to
explore before
with these Fascinating People this is
great and so we do it for a little bit
and then uh inevitably people say you
know it'll be really great if we had
some cameras in there I think oh okay
we'll put some cameras in there
and we do that and that's fine and then
they say be really great if
we did some of these for a live audience
like at the Beacon Theater or uh at the
theater in downtown LA theater uh let's
do it you know what about that and I
think oh okay then they say you know if
you're gonna be in front of an audience
be really fun if you came out first and
sort of entertain the crowd a little bit
and I went I'll do that might also be
good if you had some music behind you
you want to get Jimmy vivino and some of
the guys sure I'll do that
I realize they tricked me into doing a
television show again Twilight it's the
same thing
a couple of times I've realized that
well farewell
late night show that's the end of you
and now something new me jumping around
like an idiot in front of a live
audience with music behind me and then
interviewing the people that I
interviewed on television tell us the
big tragedy about the man who couldn't
not do a talk show it's all fun so it's
Adam it's strong and there's no danger
of this thing ending in there no it's
evolving I mean the fan episodes is
another thing that that has changed over
the past I mean we've maybe you have
done a state of the podcast since then
but I don't know I mean the fan episodes
have been another thing that we've sort
of added to the show another evolution
of the show that I think is really great
adds another dimension fans well what I
love about it is I'm talking to people
all over the world that just blows my
mind if I'm talking to someone who's in
Eastern Africa you're talking to someone
who's in Iran the fact that uh
I I always go back to this but the I I'm
always amused that we're uh infecting
the brains people in these far-off
cultures I know exactly I know but I do
love talking to these people and finding
out what their lives are like and what
they're doing and so that's that's a
gift that keeps on giving as much as I
love I mean as much as I love talking to
the celebrities uh
who are we talked to so many really
funny people and Fascinating People but
I don't know when we get a chance to
talk to someone who lives up in Wales
and they've got a really specific kind
of life and we get to a peek into that
world that blows my mind the diversity
of those conversations is really some is
a different layer that the a lot of the
celebrity episodes don't necessarily
have right right well because
celebrities are all phonies and then
like the number side is you know that we
don't need to get into it but it's very
strong it's uh I think it's something
like in the teens across the across the
board the podcast industry at the
beginning of covet like took a hit the
audience numbers took a hit I think
people stopped commuting they stopped
going out to the gym a lot of routines
changed and so there was a period of
time where there was a decrease just in
the industry for listening and I think
over time not only has have people
figured out a way to work podcasts back
into the routine a lot of the routines
have come back but even if they haven't
podcasts have come back into their lives
and now we've exceeded
pre-coveted numbers what well I think I
think it was my uh it's the neediness
that I keep putting out there Conor
O'Brien needs a friend that neediness I
think there's a sense that people felt
yeah my life changed during covid but
man I'm worried about Conan he's so
people feel better about how bad things
were because they're like at least I'm
not Conan O'Brien who is that I thought
that's where you were going I thought
that's the path you were going down no
no oh
um see he's now you're gonna make fun of
my hard G's and stuff no okay I thought
that's where you were headed what were
you headed I don't know where I was at
okay I'm just a guy a Creator I suppose
a force does the sun know that it
supplies light to the Earth no the sun
just does what it does and then uh all
life stems from the Sun so I guess I'm
like the sun a big ball of gas yeah
there we go that you got there he's
burning everything around me yeah yeah
well this is no this makes me happy this
makes me happy that the state of the
podcast is strong I'm indebted to you
Matt Gourley and I you
um we'll edit that out Adam sacks I'm
indebted to you Eduardo I mean uh and
did it to you for the good work that you
do engineering this show making it all
happen thank you sir and uh who else
my glasses on person in the room maybe
there's one more assistant to 14 years
right next to you ah yes yes of course I
do my part so that's me thanking me and
Sona you of course you're the best okay
well that's nice all right well we're
having fun we hope you're having fun
listening to this foolishness you've
said that didn't sound fun at all no
we're really having fun
way this needs to end as we go yeah love
you guys love you guys Man Group Hug
love you love you all love you oh don't
Adam when you said it it showed me to
the Bone
that was you just bro side hooked me
yeah yeah yeah you don't need to see it
dude doesn't even see humans you just
you just see metrics and demos when you
look at us did you just roofie us yeah I
love our metrics
I would love to see what Adam sees and
it's just like a bunch of ones and zeros
sort of in the shape of humans I'm a bar
graph you're a pie chart yeah you're
just a spreadsheet I love you metrics I
mean humans